the male Improvement angle is so
important for guys and it just seems to
me like why would you want guys to not
be working out boosting their
testosterone which is so pivotal to
their health their overall emotional and
physical health why would you want a
society of weak crippled men I mean how
does that help anyone and again these
are the same women that when you know
stuff comes comes crawling at them
that's dangerous if there's a war if
there's crime in their area whatever it
is they're going to throw their feminism
out the window and they're going to seek
out those strong men who by the way have
control over their emotions and can jump
and leap to remedy that problem so it's
interesting to see them trying to weaken
men knowing full well in their heart of
hearts that ultimately if you know what
did hit the fan they would need those
men
[Music]
thank you